it's a great pleasure to be back at Yale
this is our third visit and since the
depth of environmentalism and came out
in 2004 I also like to thank Dan Esty
for extending us the invitation and as
Suzanne stall for really making it
happen the other purpose of our visit is
to promote or in recruit really for our
summer fellowship program we have a
summer fellowship program called
breakthrough generation where we take
mostly graduate students and the and the
occasional exceptional undergrad to
really come with us for the summer it's
a it's a paid fellowship really for
people that are looking for a career in
policy and policy analysis in 2005 and
Ted and I are gonna or were a little
old-fashioned in some way so we're going
to actually read a specially prepared
talk for you all and we're not going to
show a single slide and there's no
twittering at all but you can but we
won't do any in early 2005 Yale invited
us to debate the essay death of
environmentalism and since then the
school has continued to demonstrate a
genuine interest in what our friend and
colleague Peter Teague has taken to
calling ecological innovation this
school in particular trains its students
to ask very hard questions we saw this
firsthand in last summer we were graced
with the presence of Yale schools
masters candidate David Mitchell who can
also tell you a little bit about the
program if you're curious but we also
see it in your flagship publication Yale
360 which under the leadership of Roger
Cohn is publishing some of the most
interesting green thought anywhere today
and so we're very grateful for this
opportunity again to reflect on the
seven years since the essay came out and
make some new arguments about what we
believe the green movement must do now
seven years ago the two of us started
interviewing America's environmental
leaders with the intention of writing a
report on the politics of global warming
for an October 2004 meeting of the
environmental grantmakers Association we
came away quite disappointed now one of
the environmental leaders we interviewed
articulated a compelling vision
or a strategy for dealing with the
challenge none expressed much much
interest in rethinking their assumptions
about the problem or the solutions we
heard again and again during the
interviews the same old riffs that we
had been hearing since the late 1980s
global warming would be solved - the
same kinds of policies that we had used
to address past pollution problems like
acid rain most were confident that John
Kerry was with their health about to be
elected president and the biggest
funders and the movement told us that
they were just a few years away from
passing cap-and-trade that October we
delivered our paper the death of
environmentalism at the at the
conference while leaders of the major
green philanthropies and green groups
hoped that the debate and I think with
it we would just go away the essay
struck a chord with many others and the
debate the fall was quite spirited a lot
of people took it quite personally
without question the most common
reaction was just I'm not dead our our
friend Adam we're back gave a speech
called his environmentalism dead where
he suggested that environmentalists make
common cause with a broader coalition of
progressive interests yells then Dean
Yale School of Forestry the environment
then Dean Gus Speth question whether
capitalism itself was compatible with
ecological sustainability and suggested
a radical shift in values was required
to deal with the problem but in the
years that followed the fortunes of
American environmentalism would
seemingly turn around in 2005 almost
exactly one year after the publication
of our essay Al Gore came to Aspen to
keynote a Yale retreat about the future
of the environmental movement gore
opened his speech asserting that
environmentalism was in fact not dead
the problem was that Republicans were
waging an assault on reason ignoring
science and misleading the public on
behalf of their fossil fuel corporate
benefactors there was nothing wrong with
environmentalism Gore said that couldn't
be rectified by clearly explained the
American public the science of global
warming and just how serious and dire
the consequences would be if we didn't
act gore hit the road with his
powerpoint a few months late' and in
just a few months later nine months
later an inconvenient truth became a
global media sensation seemingly every
magazine in this country including
Sports Illustrated
release a special green issue fortune
500 companies pledged to go carbon
neutral Paris dimmed the lights on the
Eiffel Tower solar investments became
hot even for oil companies in addition
to winning an Oscar and a Nobel Prize
Gore's movie single-handedly almost
revitalized the climate movement youth
climate activism which had virtually
been non-existent prior to 2006 exploded
on college campuses and in the fall of
2007 12,000 youth activists convened at
a conference in Washington to demand
climate policies like cap and trade
international negotiators went to Bali
at the end of that year with renewed
determination to negotiate a successor
to the Kyoto Accord in the spring of
2008 Congress restarted the dormant
effort to pass cap-and-trade legislation
and major candidates from both parties
promised to reduce carbon emissions 80%
by 2050 if as Gore famously suggested we
all we lacked to address climate the
climate crisis was political will and
you could almost convince yourself the
heavy lifting to get the world on track
to climate stabilization was mostly done
at about the same time that Gore was
giving his speech in Aspen a San
Francisco civil rights attorney named
Van Jones was in the process of turning
his criminal justice nonprofit
organization into a new wave
environmental justice group not long
after Gore accepted his Nobel Prize
Jones's book the green collar economy
became a best-seller among liberals the
subtitle of Jones's book was quote how
one solution can fix our two biggest
problems by which he meant poverty and
climate change Jones and his allies
claimed and much of the liberal
establishment came to believe that jobs
retrofitting old buildings and
installing solar panels would revitalize
the inner city save the economy
dramatically cut emissions and pay for
themselves by the onset of the 2008
election campaign clean energy and green
jobs was about the closest Democrats
came to articulating a coherent strategy
to fix the American economy and
turnaround our long-term decline and in
this sense the 2008 election was proof
of concept for an idea that the two of
us had long advocated indeed while the
death of environmentalism was born of
frustration with conventional
environmentalism it was also a call for
a new Apollo project which we had helped
found in 2002 in hopes of creating a
very different model
ecological politics one that was focused
not directly on climate change but
rather on strategies to address other
more salient public concerns like jobs
and national security through measures
that also offered substantial climate
benefits and this is largely what
Democrats did in the 2008 elections
offering Americans a compelling vision
of a clean and prosperous energy future
they had done so not by attempting to
terrify Americans into addressing
climate change indeed they hardly
mentioned climate change at all focusing
instead on the many economic and
security benefits that bringing that
building a clean energy economy would
bring and yet today environmental
efforts to address climate change and
build a green economy lie in ruins the
United States Congress the summer once
again rejected climate legislation that
even if it had succeeded would have had
virtually no impact on carbon emissions
over the coming decade the magnitude and
consequence of this defeat are still
poorly understood outside of Washington
Greens had the best opportunity in a
generation a Democratic White House
large Democratic majorities in both
houses of Congress the and yet they
banked everything on a single bill and
walked away with absolutely nothing
or rather worse than nothing since today
environmental credibility with lawmakers
of both parties is at an all-time low
meanwhile green stimulus investments
ended up creating very few jobs and many
of those that did create were low wage
and temporary custodial jobs not the
high wage manufacturing jobs that
created the American black middle-class
after World War two
and today the clean tech sector the
darling of high-tech VC's at the height
of the green bubble is in a state of
collapse as stimulus funds expire large
public deficits threaten clean energy
subsidies both here and abroad and Wall
Street firms are now in the process of
shorting clean tech stocks the picture
is no less grim internationally
Australia has abandoned its efforts to
cap its emissions Japan announced last
month that it would under no
circumstances agree to further emissions
reductions commitments under the
auspices of the Kyoto Accord the
European Union will meet its Kyoto
commitments thanks to the collapse of
Eastern Bloc economies in the early 90s
which obviously had anything to do with
global warming and the collapse of the
global economy in 2008
but not by decarbonizing its energy
economy to any demonstrable degree and
the collapse of diplomatic efforts to
negotiate legally binding emissions caps
first in Copenhagen and getting Cancun
has set the International process back
to basically where it started in 1992 in
Rio de Janeiro now in the wake of this
crash environmentalists have largely
been pointing their fingers at the usual
boogeyman they claim that the problem
has been that fossil fuel interests have
massively outspent the underdog
environmental movement funding skeptics
to mislead the public and duping the
media into giving too much credence to
skeptical views about climate change
however in reality the environmental
lobby massively outspent its opponents
in just the last two years environmental
organizations and philanthropies by our
rough estimate spent somewhere north of
1 billion dollars advocating for climate
action by contrast the US Chamber of
Commerce ExxonMobil the Koch brothers
Big Coal and the various other
well-publicized opponents of action
spent when all was said and done a very
small fraction of that indeed much of
the US energy industry including the
country's largest utilities helped to
write and lobbied for cap-and-trade
climate legislation nonetheless and
despite the enormous resources they have
spent on public communications about
climate green groups continue to accuse
the media of quote false balance by
which they mean giving equal coverage to
skeptical views of climate change with
those from climate scientists but the
phenomenon of quote unquote false
balance according to the best academic
studies of the phenomenon disappeared
after 2005 and even the very notion
completely undermines the idea that
media coverage has been biased against
climate action the complaint after all
is that the media have reported the
views of skeptics or opponents of
climate action at all the truth is that
the disparate crew of academics and
bloggers who make up the skeptic
community have told in relative
obscurity and have been largely ignored
by the mainstream media in recent years
that skeptics have nonetheless succeeded
in raising doubt among many Americans
about the reality of global warming
suggests at the very least that the
environmental community has profoundly
Mis framed this problem the propensity
to blame skeptics and fossil fuel
company
for the serial political failures of the
environmental movement should be
understood today as a tribal defense of
a collective green ego not the logical
conclusion of a dispassionate analysis
so what went wrong the green bubble of
seemingly widespread interest in climate
change in green jobs was it turns out
primarily an elite phenomenon one which
had little effect upon public opinion
about climate change public support for
action
Georgette's global warming has always
been broad and never deep and remained
largely unchanged for the entire period
indeed the only impact that either An
Inconvenient Truth or the green jobs
movement had on public opinion was to
increase public skepticism about climate
science and a polarized public support
for both climate and clean energy action
from virtually the moment that an
inconvenient truth was released public
skepticism about global warming began to
rise the Pew Research Center for the
people and the press found that from
July 2006 which shortly after Gore's
film came out to April 2008 belief that
global warming was occurring declined
from 79 to 71 percent Gallup then found
similar backlash to the movie with the
percentage of Americans who believe that
quote news of global warming was being
exaggerated unquote rising from 30
percent in March of 2006 to 35 percent
in March of 2008 Corr famously claimed
that quote the truth about the climate
crisis is an inconvenient one that means
that we are going to have to change the
way we live our lives
those apparent calls for sacrifice by
gore and other green leaders drove
rising partisan polarization John Jost a
leading political psychologist at New
York University recently demonstrated
that much of the partisan divide on
global warming can be explained through
the psychological concept of system
justification it turns out that many
Americans have a very strong
psychological need to maintain a
positive view of the existing social
order
when Gore said quote we are going to
have to change the way we live our lives
he could not have uttered a statement
better tailored to trigger system
justification among a substantial
percentage of Americans about the same
time
Green's increasingly conflated
acceptance of climate science with
acceptance of particular policy
prescriptions to oppose cap-and-trade
was implicitly among many greens and
explicitly among the most apocalyptic
ones to deny the reality of
anthropogenic warming but this just
further polarized opinion on a climate
science rather than uniting us in an
effort to address climate change
environmentalist appeals to scientific
Authority led conservatives not to
abandon their opposition to state
intervention in the energy economy but
rather to reject climate science Greens
reacted to these developments not by
toning down their rhetoric or
reconsidering their agenda in a matter
that in a manner that might be more
palatable to their opponents but rather
by cranking up the apocalyptic claims
about global warming these claims that
were increasingly inconsistent
ironically with the scientific consensus
upon whom mantle greens claimed these
efforts both further increased political
polarization among conservatives and
undermine support for action among many
others UC Berkeley political
psychologist Rob Willer recently
demonstrated through a series of very
good experiments that catastrophic
presentations of global warming actually
reduce belief in global warming but the
failure of Green Climate advocacy in
recent years goes beyond well beyond a
failure to properly frame this issue
indeed the failure of the green agenda
has been as much a function of green
groups and greens concluding that they
had a framing problem as that they
didn't when many greens and concluded
after the death of environmentalism was
that they need to reframe global warming
as an economic opportunity and not as an
ecological crisis and so carbon caps and
the quote-unquote soft energy paths of
efficiency and renewables were
repackaged as economic and jobs policy
despite little evidence of those
policies would unbalance create jobs in
fact most credible economic models of
proposed cap and trade policies
including those produced by government
agencies predicted quite the opposite
when Green groups mostly ignored that
evidence and plunged ahead with the
cap-and-trade effort the jobs question
was more than
academic there were real economic
consequences to proposals to cap carbon
emissions and those consequences had
profound political implications for the
art for their effort for the effort that
environmentalists were not going to
spend their way out of much of the
industrial Midwest is still heavily
dependent on coal-fired electricity both
for household energy use and for what
remains of the nation's struggling
manufacturing sector other regions such
as the Gulf Coast are heavily dependent
upon fossil fuel industries for jobs the
result was that while the national
debate was polarized by party there was
no such divide in regions such as the
industrial Midwest or the Gulf Coast
where there was bipartisan opposition to
policies that would significantly raise
energy prices or cost jobs in important
sectors of their regional economies the
defining moment in the fight to pass a
cap-and-trade bill through the last
Congress came came virtually before it
began a few members of Congress were
willing to expressly advocate for
policies that would raise energy prices
and in April of 2009 the Senate voted
virtually unanimously for a resolution
that cap and trade should not result in
increased energy prices this pretty well
established that any policy that passed
out of Congress would have little impact
either upon emissions or on the Devon
the deployment of clean energy from that
point on the national cap and trade
debate was little more than Kabuki
theater with advocates claiming the
proposed legislation would significantly
reduce emissions and create millions of
jobs and opponents claiming it would
wreck the economy while in reality it
would have done neither of those things
neither the version that passed the
house nor the one that died in the
Senate would have had much impact on
emissions or the nation's energy system
for at least the first decade and
perhaps several more but while the
outcome of the cap-and-trade debate was
a foregone conclusion the damage done to
both the environmental movement and the
clean energy investment agenda has been
enormous
today the political capital of the
environmental movement is lower than it
has been since the 1994 even more than
the 1994 Republican takeover of Congress
perhaps more importantly given how
poorly the national environmental
movement has chosen to expend its
capital is that greens also succeeded in
both discrediting and polarizing the
clean air
investment agenda when the jobs they had
promised to the green stimulus
investments failed to materialize and
when their efforts to reframe climate
policy as economic policy ended up
discrediting would have been a broadly
popular agenda to invest in developing
new energy technologies by rendering it
indistinguishable from the profoundly
polarizing climate debate that's the bad
news
Ted will take over on the good news and
then we'll finish we'll be done in about
twenty minutes
well thanks Michael and thanks again to
all of you at Yale for having us back
it's always a real pleasure to be here
so obviously our view is that today you
know the need to remake ecological
politics is clearly more urgent than
ever and that will require that we
actually learn something from our
failures this time around so consider
these our twelve theses for a post
environmental movement first more better
or louder climate science will not drive
the transformation of the global energy
economy the resources necessary to make
such a transport transformation will not
be forthcoming in pursuit of climate
benefits that are uncertain and far off
in the future many Greens have imagined
that as the evidence of climate change
becomes ever clearer the case for action
will become stronger but the reality is
that the more our understanding of the
full complexity of the climate system
advances the greater the uncertainty
about the impacts of climate change and
the attribution of those impacts to
anthropogenic activities will become
this is not because the evidence for
anthropogenic warming will become weaker
it will in fact become stronger but our
understanding of how that warning
warming impacts the climate system at
regional and local scales will become
harder to characterize not easier second
we need to stop trying to scare the
pants off the American pub
doing so has demonstrably backfired
climate skepticism is on the rise every
snowstorm is the subject of partisan
ranker and we are no closer to acting in
any meaningful way to address climate
change today skepticism about climate
change has been motivated by concerns
about the remedies that greens have
proposed the solution is not more
climate science but rather a different
set of remedies third the most
successful actions to address climate
change will not be justified for
environmental reasons the only two
countries to significantly decarbonize
their energy supplies over the last 40
years have been France and Sweden and
they did so for energy security reasons
in response to oil price shocks not for
environmental reasons many conservatives
are skeptical of claims made by climate
campaigners yet believe that it's a bad
idea to send a half a trillion dollars
or so a year abroad for foreign imported
oil which obviously brings with it a
host of non enviable environmental
national security and energy security
problems others simply see 3 million
current air pollution deaths a year as a
far higher priority so we need to put
shared solutions at the center of our
politics not our our view of climate
science fourth we need to stop imagining
that we will solve global warming
through behavior changes there are no
doubt many good reasons for those of us
with enough affluence and control over
the material circumstances of our lives
to turn away from a cumulative
consumption but we should not imagine
this to be a climate strategy what most
screens mean when they suggest that we
need to fundamentally change our way of
life it turns out isn't so fundamentally
at all they mostly mean that we need to
stop the crass consumerism live in
denser cities and use public transit and
while there is much to recommend each of
these particular remedies none will have
much impact upon the trajectory of
global emissions
that's because much of
world already lives in dense cities more
and more of us every day as the world
burn eise's relatively few of us
globally today have the means to consume
crassly or even own an automobile and
the reality is that global development
and urbanization are salutary trends
they bring with them the opportunity for
billions of us to live longer healthier
and freer lives
but these trends also suggest that grit
the green obsession with moralizing
against profligate American lifestyles
is entirely irrelevant to the future
disposition of the global climate or
much anything else that really matters
to the big ecological challenges that we
will face in the coming century more and
more of the world will adopt the very
living patterns that greens have so long
valorized and as they do they will use
vastly more energy and resources not
less v we have to stop treating climate
change as if it were a traditional
pollution problem as we noted in our
book climate changes as different from
past pollution problems as nuclear
warfare is from gang violence climate
change will not be solved with end of
pipe solutions like smokestacks
scrubbers institutes to its treatments
plants that work for past pollution
problems rather it will require us to
rebuild the entire global energy system
with technologies that we mostly don't
have today in any form that could
conceivably scale to meet the challenge
6 we will not regulate or price our way
to a clean energy economy regulatory and
pricing solutions tend to succeed when
we have good low-cost alternatives to
the activities we are attempting to
discourage or eliminate we dealt with
acid rain once we had access to low
sulfur coal from the western United
States and reached an international
agreement that phase out CFCs only once
the dupont demonstrated that they could
produce a cheap alternative at scale
greens have in recent years substituted
the almighty market in response to a
carbon price signal for their past faith
in command and control regulations but
the substitution problem is large
the same without cheap technologies
carbon prices will have to be
prohibitively high to drive a quick
transition to a low-carbon economy
seventh we need to acknowledge that this
so-called soft energy path is a dead end
the notion that the nation might meet
its future energy needs through
renewable energy and low-cost energy
efficiency has defined virtually all
environmental energy proposals since the
1960s and was codified into dogma by
anti-nuclear activists turned efficiency
consultant Amory Lovins
in his 1976 Foreign Affairs article
Lovings claimed that efficiency would
allow America to dramatically reduce its
total energy use and that renewable
energy technologies like solar and wind
power were ready to replace fossil fuels
but the reality is that for centuries
the global economy has used ever more
energy even as it has used energy ever
more efficiently and renewable energy
which Lovins and others were claiming
even as early as the late 70s was
cheaper than fossil energy remains
expensive and difficult to scale
renewables still cost vastly more than
fossil based energy even before we cost
the cost of so calculate the costs
associated with storing and transmitting
intermittent forms of energy wind energy
according to the latest aia estimates
that still cost 50% more than coal or
gas solar costs three to five times as
much in the end what the south energy
path has given us is coal-fired power
plants mountaintop removal global
warming and an economy that used 50
percent more energy not solar panels and
wind farms
viii we will not internalize the full
cost of fossil fuels even were we able
to agree upon what they actually were
like a climate science upon which they
are based economic models that attempt
to model the social cost of carbon
emissions are endlessly disputable don't
like the result change the estimated
climate sensitivity the damage
exponential discount rate or any number
of other in some shion's until you
arrive at one that you do like so the
degree that we do internalize the cost
of carbon that will be determined
by the tolerance within specific
political economies for policies that
increase energy costs and our argument
has for a long time then that that's
very low ninth we will need to make
clean energy technologies much cheaper
in order to dem decarbonize the global
energy economy clean energy technologies
where they have been deployed at all
still require vast public subsidies in
order to be commercially viable this is
simply not a recipe for bringing those
technologies to scale and simple as
simply subsidizing more of the same old
technologies will bring down the cost
incremental e but not enough to displace
fossil fuels at a rate sufficient to
have much impact on emissions there will
be no significant action to address
global warming no meaningful caps or
other regulatory frameworks and no
global agreement to limit emissions
until the alternatives to fossil fuels
are much better and cheaper and this
will require technical technological
innovation on a vast scale and will
require sustained state support for
radical innovation through large
investments in basic science research
and development demonstration and
commercialization of new energy
technologies 10th we're going to have to
get over our suspicions of technology
and especially nuclear power there is no
credible path to reducing global carbon
emissions without an enormous expansion
of nuclear power it is the only
low-carbon technology we have today with
a demonstrated capability to generate
large quantities of centrally generated
electrical power it is the low carbon
technology of choice for the rest of the
world even uber green nations such as
Germany and Sweden have reversed plans
to phase out nuclear power as they have
begun to reconcile their energy needs
with their climate commitments 11th we
will need to a Brit embrace again the
role of the state as a direct provider
of public goods the modern environmental
movement born of new left rejection of
so
authority of all sorts has embraced the
notion of state regulation and even
creep state creation of private markets
while rejecting the generative role of
the state in the modern environmental
imagination government promotion of
Technology whether nuclear power the
Green Revolution syn fuels or ethanol is
almost always bad
never mind that virtually the entire
history of American industrialization
and technological innovation is the
story of government investments in the
development and commercialization of new
technologies think of a transformative
technology over the last century
computers the internet pharmaceuticals
drugs
Sartain pharmaceutical drugs jet
turbines cellular phones nuclear power
and what you will find again and again
and again is the government's investing
in those technologies at a scale that
private firms simply cannot replicate 12
biggest beautiful
the rising economies of the developing
world will continue to develop whether
we want them to or not the solution to
the ecological crises wrought by
modernity technology and progress will
be more modernity technology and
progress the solutions to the ecological
challenges based by a planet of nine
billion of six billion going on nine
billion will not be decentralized energy
technologies like solar panels small
school upscale organic agriculture and a
drawing of unenforceable boundaries
around what what remains of our
ecological inheritance be it the
rainforests of the Amazon or the
chemical composition of the atmosphere
rather they will be large central
station power technologies that can meet
the energy needs of billions of people
increasingly living in the dense mega
cities of the global south and that are
capable of doing that without emitting
carbon further intensification of
industrial scale agriculture to meet
their nutritional needs of a population
that is not only growing but eating
higher up the food chain and a whole
suite of other agricultural desalination
it's desalinization
other technologies for gardening planet
earth that might us allow us not only to
bolt pull back from forests and other
threatened ecosystems but also to create
new ones enclosing the great ecological
challenges that our generation will face
demand and ecological politics that is
generative not restrictive an ecological
politics capable of addressing global
warming will require us to re-examine
virtually every strand of post-war green
ideology from Paul Ehrlich's warnings of
a Population Bomb to the club of Rome's
limits to growth contemporary ecological
politics have consistently embraced
green Malthusian through Zionism despite
the fact that the Malthusian premise has
persistently failed for the better part
of three centuries indeed the Green
Revolution was exponentially increasing
agricultural yields at the very moment
that Ehrlich was predicting mass
starvation and the cereal predictions of
Peak Oil and various other resource
collapses that have followed have
continued to fail now this does not mean
that Malthusian outcomes are impossible
but neither are they inevitable we do
have a choice in the matter but the
choice is not the choice that greens
have long imagined the choice that
humanity faces is not whether to
constrain our growth development and
aspirations or die it is whether we will
continue to innovate and accelerate
technological progress in order to
thrive human technology and ingenuity
have repeatedly confounded Malthusian
predictions yet Green ideology continues
to cast a suspect suspect eye towards
the very technologies that have allowed
us to avoid resource and ecological
catastrophes now those solutions will
require environmentalist not only to
embrace technology but also to ambient
abandoned the small is beautiful
ethic that is also characterized
environmental thoughts since the 1960s
we the
most secure affluent and thoroughly
modern human beings to have ever lived
upon the planet must abandon both the
dark zero-sum Malthusian visions and the
idealized and nostalgic fantasies for a
simpler more bucolic past in which
humans lived in harmony with nature to
an older generation of environmentalists
these observations will seem
antithetical to everything they have
imagined environmentalism to be if in
2004 we argued that environmentalism
needed to die today it's clear that it
did die what killed it was neither our
essay nor fossil fuel funded skeptics
nor this or that tactical failure by
green leaders or Democratic politicians
rather it died of old age the world in
which we live economically
technologically politically and most
importantly ecologically has so
profoundly changed that the very
foundations upon which contemporary
environmental politics was constructed
no longer hold what comes next is on is
still unwritten and if we can find
inspiration in anything today it should
be in this fact alone and so we leave
you today with the words of a great
American novelist of our own generation
Dave Eggers Eggers lost his own lost
both his parents to cancer at the age of
21 and reflecting on the experience and
how it had shaped his life he observed
the following on the one hand you were
so completely bewildered that something
so surreal and incomprehensible could
happen at the same time suddenly the
limitations or hesitations that you
might have imposed on yourself fall away
there's a weird optimistic recklessness
that could easily be construed as
nihilism but is really the opposite you
see that there is a beginning and an end
and that you only have a certain amount
of time to act and you want to get
started so thank you thanks for having
us again
if you have a question just bringing
microphone to you were recording this so
related questions the first sort of
sweeping arguments that are based in
large part on denigrating people and you
seem to have done that rather much and
it is attached to the question of why do
you find the need to frame the argument
in such either/or you could agree with
us or you can agree with them I speak
into this microphone does the microphone
I should use well we think there is a
choice we do think that you cannot have
an apocalyptic
Malthusian worldview choosing soft
energy technologies only well I
appreciate that you don't agree with it
I think our view is that there are some
serious choices that have to be made and
that they are mutually exclusive in
other words you can't be pro nuclear and
anti nuclear at the same time you can't
believe that renewables and efficiency
are going to be sufficient to replace a
fossil energy economy and not believe
that so there are some pretty important
questions here you can't believe that
apocalyptic discourses motivate the
American public and that they alienate
the American public so I think we are
actually making a set of claims here now
you can I would love for you to tell me
which claim you disagree with but
yes we are making we have a point of
view we think there are some hard
choices that have to be made here happy
to debate what those are but I think
just sort of it's sort of like you're
not you're not offering me something to
disagree with just that we're making a
sweeping statement so you move fluidly
it strikes me between two sets of claims
one set of claims has to do with
presentation and one set of claims has
to do with the underlying truth values
of what do you of what the situation is
right so just because it's wrong to
present a catastrophic view for tactical
reasons doesn't say anything one way or
the other about whether catastrophe is
possible than possible etc in that
spirit and addressing the underlying
truth claims that you're making I wonder
are there limits to human technological
ingenuity and if not how do you know
yeah I mean you know these these become
the kinds of theoretical questions that
or I should say hypothetical questions
that I don't think are particularly
helpful you know look at some point the
Sun is going to burn out and you know
life on the planet earth will be
extinguished at some point the you know
universe if you believe that it's not an
expansionary universe will stop
expanding and will start contracting so
kind of theoretical questions about is
there any limit to human ingenuity I
think our less interesting than then
particular and specific questions you
know are we going to run out of oil yeah
we probably will at some point is there
no possibility that that human ingenuity
and technology will allow us to develop
new and better forms of energy that's
where you know I would depart from the
kind of idea that there are sort of
these hard limits to resources will
you know if we keep plundering the seas
and the ways that we've been plundering
the Seas we'll all of our fisheries
collapse probably is it conceivable that
we may kind of continue to develop and
improve and expand aquaculture such that
we might actually meet sort of human
desires for you know fish you know I
think that's probably pretty likely you
know and I think you can kind of start
to go through these whole questions you
know I think that I would I would make
the case that that you know whether you
posit that sort of somewhere out at the
end of the next century with nine
billion people or ten billion people
everything's going to run out or not I
think is you know I think that we are
unlikely to solve that problem by by
deciding that sort of nine billion of us
who will soon be living on the planet
are going to sort of not consume a lot
more resources because I think it's
inevitable that you know even if we sort
of those of us in the developed world
turn away from sort of really
conspicuous consumption I mean the math
is pretty overwhelming you take nine
billion people even living that you know
say an average of $15,000 per capita you
know income which is the supposed
happiness threshold where you don't need
to consume anything more and you don't
get any happier you're still going to
like you know double or triple your
energy use and most of your other
resource use so we better figure out how
people are kind of kind of live much you
know continue to live improving have
improving living standards through sort
of technological innovation that allow
us to kind of continue to support that
because I think we would argue it's the
only way that's going to happen
I'm going to say something stinky
that'll make me really popular here I'm
struck by your first thesis more better
and louder climate science won't drive
the transformation and you know here we
are at school environmental studies and
and we're scientists here most of us and
what strikes me is the presumption in
that thesis that we are activists
scientists that that that is that more
better and or louder climate science
will in fact find that we need a
transformation it's possible to better
climate science might actually show us
that some people will be very hard hit
by climate change but overall the
overall impacts maybe are not worth
worrying that much about an adaptation
may be the best strategy and and my root
my point that sort of related to that is
that climate change seems to have sucked
a lot of the air out of the
environmental conversation that we were
having 10 or 15 years ago there there
are still many environmental problems to
worry about that have little or nothing
to do with climate change ocean dumping
overfishing hazardous air pollutants
just to name a few and I'm wondering if
you can comment on that because as I
look at your 12 theses like 9 or 10 of
them have to do with climate change
almost exclusively right well thanks for
the question and to be clear it was the
theses were on the topic of a post
environmental politics on climate but I
do want to actually want to just agree
with you I mean I like I think I agree
with everything you said I think our
view of the science and you know and
this is in part based not based on that
nature the trim bath piece the tremble
piece in nature was that earlier this
year or is it really a last year
no no earlier last year you know where
he points out that the next working
group IPCC working group report is
actually going to you know much larger
uncertainties around impacts not fewer
so I think that's the way of agreeing
with you that it's this is not going to
be a question that's resolved by the
science there will not be a moment when
we say okay now we know exactly what's
going to happen in the future I think
when your second you think was also very
important I think you know we spent like
the last ten you know the environmental
movement really overwhelmingly a huge
amount of time of loss
five or ten years on climate you know we
think there was a lot of work that could
have been done and should still be done
on conventional air pollutants that
would actually end up phasing out a lot
of you know dirty coal plants
establishing a higher and plus a carbon
price than we currently have and and
would frankly have gotten you a much
larger political majority on some
environmental concerns than I think the
way that the climate change did and I am
I agree with you on the on kind of
global environmental problems I mean
habitat
you know rainforest destruction habitat
destruction and these things are all
also accelerating as countries seek to
convert forest lands into ranching and
agricultural lands and you know we can
kind of go global warming is this big
threat to species but truthfully you
know a far stronger causal link is from
just direct habitat destruction and
that's an issue where you know what
we're a lot of new thinking is also I
think merited so yeah thanks I'm gonna
we're in a favor of students just no
offense but we are we are we are at a at
the Yale School of Forestry we're in a
favor of grad students and students so
so I just have a quick question so it
seems like you know your third point I
think it was the is that climate change
will you know climate change solutions
won't be driven by sort of environmental
values or that won't sort of underline
that and in related to that it seems
like a lot of your list sort of points
that is I think Georgia gestured at so
technological change and the ability of
like large-scale technological change to
release all these problems but I'm
wondering what you just what your view
is about the values that drive that
technological change like what are our
environmental do environmental values of
a place and sort of the science or the
technology entrepreneurship to guide
that in a way that might be useful or
are there other values that should be
there that we should be encouraging or
is it valueless I mean I don't
personally believe it would be valueless
but is that your view of your question
yeah it's it's a great correct question
and I think you know the answer there is
yes I mean I mean part of our call is
for environmentalists to actually you
know
or post environmentalism needs too much
more clearly embraced technology as the
solution not the problem and that of
course means bringing environmental
values and environmental vision to those
technologies you know you know nuclear
power and desalinization might let us
allow us to create rain forests in the
desert you know GMOs may allow us to you
know pull back from forests by intensive
by getting higher agricultural yields
you know there's a whole set of
technological solutions here that you
know have I would argue or not would not
be entirely motivated by ecological
concerns but would sort of in in
substantial part be motivated by those
concerns you know at the same time and
back to this question of well what are
we going to run out I mean right now you
have two billion people on the planet
who don't have you know the problem for
them is not that fossil fuels are too
cheap it's that they're too expensive
they have no access to modern energy at
all and as you go from a planet of six
or seven billion to a planet of eight
nine ten billion that problem becomes
more severe so actually coming up with
cheap scalable low-carbon technologies
gets motivated not only by a desire to
deal with climate and other
environmental issues but also to sort of
meet the aspirations and and and and
divide desires for modernization and
development for billions of people who
you know literally without modern energy
it is very difficult to live you know
anything that begins to approach modern
living standards so we think there's a
sort of a range of motivations you know
again most of them salya Tory around
sort of applying technology to solve
social problems arguably what we've been
doing for four you know the entire
history of the species
you know and really before we were
humans if you look at things like early
pre-human tool-making and things like
that so you know I think our argument
would be that these are that you know
this sort of ecological concerns you
know would be one of the major sort of
animating drives towards an embrace of
technology as opposed to a suspicion of
it and that's obviously sort of at a
core kind of ideologically of a lot of
what we're arguing needs to happen we're
having to take more unless you need to
unless we need to kind of move on to
reception or whatever I mean I I like
that the students are asking questions
now it's okay three more and then we'll
be great wine on the subject of energy
you were emphasizing technological
innovation while it seemed like you were
at the same time dismissing we knew what
the potential of renewable energy and
energy efficiency did I interpret
correctly then that you're putting all
your eggs into the nuclear basket that's
not quite right our view is that you
need technology innovation you need
pretty radical innovation on all of them
all of the major energy technologies so
yeah including nuclear I mean just to
give you a sense of the scale challenge
if you want to meet the the the target
of 450 parts per million million of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and
then you know and as climate
stabilization target you have to build a
single one gigawatt nuclear power plant
every day between now and 2050 if you
want to build a wind if you want to say
I don't like nuclei we do it through
wind farms you have to build three wind
farms the size of Cape Wind that's the
wind farm that they've been working on
for 15 years that they can't seem
they're having a hard time getting built
because of all the local opposition or
you have to build about three of the
Mojave deserts biggest solar thermal
plants plus you need backup
so the technological task is just
enormous so our view is that
it would be foolish to dismiss any of
these important low-carbon technologies
they're all different they all have
different needs
solar panels need much higher
efficiencies in terms of converting
sunlight to electricity
you know nuclear I think I think our
view is that you need to move towards
mass manufactured as much smaller plants
to avoid the high costs of construction
I think you also get much safer plants
you need radical advances and materials
technology to get better batteries you
need a whole set of things that happen
to fully electrify the transportation
sector our critique has been that the
environmental movement's has been wedded
to what what has been called a soft
energy path which says that efficiency
and renewables are the only way to go
and we think that that approach in the
anti-nuclear part of the environmental
move in the 70s really gave way to a
huge expansion of coal I mean quite
clearly when we started when we really
said we're going to build more nuclear
plants in this country what we did is
build a lot more a lot more coal plants
this time we're gonna start building a
lot of a lot more gas plants and I think
our concerns that that's still not going
to deliver the kind of radical
innovation that's gonna be required to
power a world of 9 billion high energy
consuming people I couldn't see which if
you had your hand at first but maybe I
go ahead yeah you're in the front yeah
thanks I'd like to speak to ask about
two issues one is values you frame many
of your solutions in these sort of
valueless ways about bringing people
together who have different motivations
but as the first questioner said you
definitely include an attack upon the
motivating values of traditional
environmentalists as something that has
caused them to go astray and that's a
very very hard thing to to get over and
to approach even for young
environmentalists and if you really want
leadership on these completely new
innovative solution
how where's that going to come from if
not the environmental movement and how
will we shift our values to be able to
put some of your ideas into practice and
then that brings me sort of
right to my next point which is a
question you said we can't hold opposing
views right we can't both believe in
utopia and dystopia we can't both
believe that nuclear energy is the
solution to climate change and something
terrible but I certainly believe in both
those things at the same time I think
that nuclear energy is seems like a
really great solution to climate change
and I have no idea what we will do with
the waste without destroying the
communities where it goes how do we
resolve those tensions if we can't hold
them both at once I mean what what is
environmentalism if not this holding of
tensions well on the first question I
would just I would observe a couple of
things I mean the first is is the you
know I obviously I think in this talk we
suggested a couple of things that for
environmentalists to actually kind of
pursue you know ecological solutions in
ways that can kind of sort of bring them
together with folks who have
traditionally rejected both they're sort
of remedies and their worldview they're
gonna have to let go of some ideas that
have really animated a lot of modern
environmentalism for a long time you
know and these include these sort of
suspicions of Technology the sort of
predictions of imminent collapse the
sort of remedies sort of focused on sort
of restricting human activities in all
sorts of ways so we are suggesting that
environmentalists are going to have to
kind of really pretty profoundly sort of
rethink some some long-held assumptions
about both how the world works and what
it will take to solve ecological
problems if they're you know going to be
cut part of of real ecological solutions
and you know I don't want to
underestimate that that's a little hard
you get used to kind of seeing the world
in a particular way and having someone
come and say stop doing that isn't isn't
easy on the other hand we think it's
inevitable in other words this really
isn't about Michael and I coming in here
and telling you all you guys you know
will do this and don't do that I mean
what I think we've always felt that what
we were doing was actually sort of
narrating a shift in ecological politics
that was inevitable and it was
inevitable literally because the nature
of the kinds of ecological challenges we
are facing today are so profoundly
different than the ones in which sort of
modern environmental ideology sort of
came of age dealing with so our view is
that that's gonna that is what's driving
this it's not about me convincing you of
anything it's that you know as I think
environmental thought leaders and new
generations of environmentalist sort of
really get their heads around what these
issues really are about I think they are
going to kind of come to their
conclusion these conclusions on their
own the technology - I mean I think our
view is that all technologies have
unintended consequences some of those
unintended consequences are really
positive like all of the tech major
technologies that power your iPhone or
your smartphone were we're spin-offs of
military technologies every single one
you know the internet for example was a
way to communicate during nuclear war
that's the great thing about technology
right is that we don't you don't have to
embrace the Cold War or support nuclear
weapons to support a whole set of
technologies spin-off from it there's
also negative constant negative
unintended consequences of technology
and there are negative unintended
consequences of all technologies and
that the I think the mistake we would I
think we wrote a recent paper it's going
to be published in Orion in the summer
which argues that we need to redefine
hubris as this hope that humans could
ever live in the world without
unintended consequences it is part of
living in the world that you're going to
have unintended consequences so you're
in a you're in a in a situation where
you have to evaluate risks and you have
to make choices
ten I came of age in the anti-nuclear
movement you know we went you know we
were went to the nuclear anti-nuclear
protests we came you know we were raised
on the gospel of Amory Lovins so we've
come up our own view on this has changed
radically over the Overlook and it's
really been an assessment of risk I look
at the risk of catastrophic climate
change at frankly the three million air
pollution deaths that we have a year
from from fossil combustion and also
wooden dumb frankly and and I kind of go
the nuclear waste problem pales in
comparison to that risk assessment pales
I mean it's just I just that's not to
say that there's not a nuclear waste
problem it's to say that the you this is
why what we want to say is you actually
do have to make choices
we are gonna right now environmental
groups are having to choose whether
they're going to support a clean energy
standard that the president is proposing
that includes nuclear power for example
so that's what I meant to say about it
it is not to say that there is that the
world is not filled with ambiguities and
contradictions because it's also
obviously filled with those two yeah so
I guess we promised this would be the
last one and everybody can go home or
you can come and argue with us more in
the hallway that's what we're here for
thank you my question was you seemed a
heavily discount the impact that you
know local or sort of opposition from
the right has had on the failure to pass
of some of these bills and you know I
find it interesting because if we look
historically I mean the behaviors are
there I mean we've seen the opposition
we've seen that they are funded by you
know coal oil interests in a lot of
cases they are big oil and coal and so
I'm curious what makes you think that
just proposing this approach that will
you know not penalize oil or coal all
these carbon fuels but that will
subsidize technologies that will
substitute the the products of those
interests why would those Congress with
congressmen and senators sort of you
know vote YES for that when that will we
and the people that fund them I mean
what what's to stop them from from
blocking this look what we are not here
to suggest is that any of this will be
done without conflict absolutely there
will be battles to fight the question is
on what terms and on what battlefields
are you going to fight and our point is
not the discount that there's been
significant opposition and not
insignificant amounts of money spent on
it but frankly this idea that sort of
environmentalists were this sort of
David versus the Goliath outgunned by
fossil fuel interests is just ridiculous
the environmental movement spent a
billion dollars over the last two years
alone at least probably substantially
more communicating and advocating for
action on climate change this is the
best funded social movement in the
history of humanity the the the
resources at the disposal of the
environmental movement are enormous so I
think our point is that when you are
able to actually significantly out spend
your opponents out communicate them
dominate the airwaves dominate media
coverage and how media coverage is
framed around these issues and you are
still serially losing these battles then
you've probably defined the fight in the
wrong way and that's not to say that
defining the fight in a different way
will eliminate the fight it means it
will put you in much better position to
enact the kind of changes that need to
be enacted if you are actually you know
offering the American public you know
some compelling vision for what the
future looks like how we get there
that's in keeping with sort of American
faith and Technology faith in innovation
and invention in the role that the
federal the American state has played
for over a hundred years in driving
every major technological transformation
that we've been through
you know I would note and you know
obviously the circumstances are much
worse now than they were two years ago
but you even you know you kind of
compare the fact that Obama was actually
willing to get up there and not only
talk about that stuff in his State of
the Union address but leave you know
spend the first third of his State of
the Union address on that where it's
just been a struggle to get him to say
anything about climate change and even
there it was all coded you know
market-based systems and and I'm not
even going to actually name the thing
that we're gonna try to do because no
one can understand it and when they
understand if they don't like it
so you know just that comparison at
least suggests pretty strongly to us
that a kind of strategy that's based on
that kind of sort of meta framing about
what we're doing and why we're doing it
is going to be a lot more successful
than what we've been trying to do on
climate for twenty years before we and I
just want to say that you know we'll be
out there having our reception and
arguing with people who want to argue
with us we've also got our book here and
yeah we like we like it when young
people and students read it so if you
but if you're poor and you can't afford
I'll just give you a copy so it's ten
bucks by the way so we'll be out there
in a minute